greetings apiece welcome to the D Sharma
dear host you're watching the Dean show
every week new show exciting exciting
and you're tuning in and you went from
maybe being obsessed with a boyfriend
then you learn about the Dean this way
of life
that's a complete way of life and now
you left off being obsessed with a
boyfriend and doing it the wrong way to
doing it the right way now you're
obsessed with getting a husband getting
a wife and now you're in the strife now
it's very difficult you're seeing it as
it's it's tough it's challenging you
went through all the matrimonial sites
and you've been paired up with the wrong
person
you're just not clicking and my next
guest went through all of the same drama
and he went from this site to that site
to that person that person finally he
made it and he's gained so much
experience so if you were just about to
give up and you tuned in to the Dean
show there's hope yet because my next
guest he's gonna help us benefit from
his experiences and give another door to
an avenue that you can take so hopefully
you can find that right husband or the
right wife and do things the right way
we'll be right back here on a Dean show
my next guest don't go anyway
this is the so I went from saying in the
beginning opening many people they went
from being obsessed with a girlfriend to
a boyfriend they finally learned the
Dean yes they went away from all that
because that woman she's not talking
about getting test driven and he's
straight sick of test driving exist what
are the benefits of marriage now
hamdullah
marriage first first and foremost it
saves us from the fitna of the world you
know unfortunately we live in a society
where Haram is just surrounding us 24/7
is an end it's it's much easier to
commit yourself into Haram than to do it
the right way to do it with keeping in
mind the Sharia philosophy napela
and alhamdulillah once somebody gets
married you can enjoy the benefits of
you know the the January interactions
but do it in a way that's pleasing to
your Creator
now you said one word and I can't let
you get away what you said Sharia yes
now some some people who just you know
they love bashing the sound they hear
this word it's a red light what do you
mean when you say Sherea Sherea in
simple terms is essentially the the laws
of the Creator the do's and the don'ts
as simple as that and Sharia is not
something to be scared of because it's
something that's just and peaceful to
the entire society for Muslims and
non-muslims alike
yeah Moses brought Sharia Jesus
charities Sharia
you know being good to family of Sharia
praying or Sharia this is all part of
the city all right absolutely
okay now marriage is part of the
institution that's another part of the
city a correct correct and what motive
motivated you so people can also benefit
we go deeper into this to get into Maron
just for your personal experience just
in a condensed version right I mean I I
basically tried to follow what our our
religion teaches which is to first and
foremost go to your parents to your
relatives to your friends to the imam of
the masjid and i did all of that but
unfortunately you know first of all
marriage will only happen when allah
sunnatullah has destined it so in a way
I wasn't doing anything wrong i what i
was doing was sort of getting frustrated
with some of the tools and the resources
that were available and so initially
when i went through all the the people
that i knew and they kept for whatever
reason bringing the wrong kind of person
that I was really not interested in I
eventually went on to the matrimonial
websites yeah to sort of do my own dirty
work and again you know there's a
plethora of matrimonial web sites out
there and some of them are good some of
them are not so good but generally
speaking most of them had certain issues
that that I felt could be improved upon
and so alhamdulillah from the laughter
looking for three very long years I
humble I got married to a wonderful
sister and right after we got married I
actually discussed with her and I and I
proposed my idea that I wanted to
utilize my professional skills as a
programmer and my background of being a
student of knowledge and having
connections with the ulema and the shoe
of the community and also using my
experience of going through this journey
how can I put all these things together
to make it easier for those that follow
now how can we benefit from your
experiences now you you have a lot of
experience because you went through I
mean can we safely say almost all of the
the matrimonial sites out there yes
right so you gained a lot of experience
we want extract some of that so our
viewers can benefit and not make maybe
some of the mistakes you might have made
you've learned a lot so we can benefit
what are some of the difficulties the
challenges you face you know so like I
said there there are a lot of websites
out there and some of them are good some
of them are not so good the biggest
problem that I
in my humble opinion is that most of the
matrimonial websites out there are there
as a business to make money they're not
really interested in benefiting people
to connect for the purpose of getting
married and in fact once people get
married they lose a customer so it's
almost to their benefit to keep you
perpetually looking and following
through this frustration that's one
thing second thing is you know it's the
internet so there is really very little
control of what you can do and what you
cannot do and so most of us you know
those that are trying to be practicing
and fearful of God's laws we want to do
it the right way and most of these
websites will not have controls in place
to watch you yeah and basically you can
do whatever you want and so you get into
all kinds of fitnah you know
communicating with people in a way or in
a manner that's not pleasing to to god
and then the third sort of problem is
because it's an open medium to the whole
world you get all kinds of people with
bad intentions some of them trying to
scam you for money or just their board
so they want to just fool around with
somebody else's emotions so you get like
a whole you know suite of people that
just add to the frustration of somebody
who's sincerely looking to get married
for the for the sake of Allah for the
for the right reasons
well okay so what I would say is my
experience has essentially benefited me
in creating resources that that have the
right controls in place so that we
minimize the Haram or the fitna and also
maximize the chances of success by
bringing together a group of people that
have a lot of commonality already that
are already looking for the same kind of
thing so that you have a much higher
chance of success what are some of the
problems that you've seen also over time
now thank god you're married now right
i'm Dalila okay so now that you have
gone through all of these challenges
what are some of the other things that
you've seen have you seen night because
we know the Deen is complete this way of
life from the Creator is very straight
forward the problem peace be upon him he
said all young people it's
can afford go ahead and get married yes
right and he also instructed the parents
of a good honest and righteous person of
sound character his Deen is intact comes
to marry your daughter Miriam otherwise
there'll be great corruption sitting on
the land right absolutely so now we have
clear instruction here
did you see the opposite happening from
the parents yes unfortunately I mean
there's a whole variety of reasons for
why I feel young people today find it
difficult to get married
I mean hundl I've been in this this work
serving the community to try to get
young people connected for marriage and
I've seen a whole suite of problems some
problems that are you know fall on the
side of the parents some on the side of
the sisters and some on the brothers and
some society as a whole so you touched
upon something very important a lot of
times I have personally seen while I'm
trying to help people get married is the
brother and the sister actually mush a
lot good for each other they're
compatible maybe they're a little bit
young but you know both of them are
sincerely looking to please Allah and
get married for the right reasons but
sometimes it's a parent's that actually
do more disservice to their children
than good and oftentimes they don't
realize it and for example if I may cite
some examples sometimes let's say a
younger brother who was still
potentially a student but has you know
good potential he has a bright future
but he doesn't have much money he's a
good practicing Muslim he's a good
character and everything and the sister
is interested in such a brother but then
the parents of the girl would shoot him
down because he's not a doctor or a
lawyer or he's not making enough money
and so similarly on the other side
sometimes let's say a brother is from
India a particular city in India and he
his parents want him to marry a specific
girl from a specific cultural background
and so they lose our opportunities for a
good girl who who may have been very
good and compatible for him so sometimes
parents actually do cause a lot of harm
than good
I like we're gonna get more into this
when take a break take a break take a
break get some juice some kool-aid
whatever the case
and we write back take a refresher be
right back with more on his hot topic so
a marriage for my brother here Hasan
he's right back on the detail I want you
to imagine you wake up and in front of
you are a bunch of guys running around
kicking a ball no goals no lines no
rules what would you think but is that
your life surely every sport has its
goal every game has its end it has its
objective it has its rules how about
life how about our life isn't there a
goal to life isn't there a purpose an
objective that we have to reach we think
so the Koran tells us that we exist in
order to worship God and worshiping God
means knowing God as the Quran says when
the holocrons inner will insert in early
ibadah worship though is not some narrow
small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal back here on the Deen
show we went from many people went from
like we talked about the beginning
obsessed with me having a boyfriend now
they realize the purpose of life
complete and half your Deen is a
marriage now you have this institution
of marriage you protect the lineage of
your children protect yourself from
diseases and all the other things now
the evil outcome that comes with
fornication and doing it the wrong way
but doing it the right way a law's way
the creator's way you got so many
blessings right and now there's some
obstacles you went through a lot and get
married you went to all the matrimonial
so I want to benefits from your
experience we were talking about the the
parents now we know that parents
obviously they care about their gems you
know their children they don't want
anybody
who's gonna you know be like a wolf
coming in and sheeps closing so it's
obviously encourage of the parents are
involved but sometimes people overstep
the grounds right
yeah these high high demands
you know 50,000 60,000 on the Maho right
right the Prophet peace be upon him said
the simplest marriage the best marriage
are the simplest one so now you have
parents sometimes okay the guy comes he
has good character good Dean and now
they want like hundred thousand have you
seen some of this happening oh yes
absolutely I mean it's actually very
prevalent in our society where the
parents would demand such outrageous
mothers that are just not doable for
them for the guy and then one of two
things happen either the guy just says
okay I will do it just to marry the girl
and he has absolutely no intention of
paying them aha which is actually very
wrong because it's an obligation upon
you or sometimes the brother sincerely
wants to pay but he is just unable to
and so therefore he misses out on a good
girl and the girl misses out on a good
guy another problem that I've seen is
that sometimes kids actually do want to
give that respect to their parents to
say you know you are my guardian you
have the right to choose for me but the
parents kind of abused that that respect
because the parents have a certain image
of what their children should marry and
sometimes that image is diagonally
opposite of what the child wants and so
the child is constantly giving this
respect to their parents of bringing
candidates and eventually keeping on
saying no because it the candidates that
are being brought are not matching what
the person actually wants so there's a
lot of time wasted and a lot of
frustrations and and I think the only
piece of advice I could give to parents
and children as first of all children
should continue to give that respect to
their parents you know unless one of
them has given that right to the parents
to help you choose your spouse these are
adults now they're not even children
right right right
adults and at the same time parents
don't go overboard in imposing on what
you want but to you know have that
honest conversation with your children
and really find out what do they like
what are their interests and hobbies and
what what do they see as a
an ideal spouse for their marriage let's
go into some other let's bring things we
want to bring things down to reality I
mean we're fallible human beings we make
mistakes sometimes we need the reminder
and remind of benefits the believers so
now you have also a growing trend of
women then now they want to finish
school or also men who want to finish
school and now the women end up you know
neglecting the avenue of marriage and
they end up getting a degree right but
they end up passing up that marriage
it's kind of like the you missed the
boat and now you're maybe what like in
late 20s 30s right and now what happens
next
yeah this is another very serious
problem actually a lot of women
rightfully so you know they want to get
an education they want to get a career
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that but unfortunately sometimes
they put so much weight on getting a
career and education that they naturally
get a little bit older and unfortunately
in our community sometimes you know
brothers are looking for a specific age
category maybe they want to have a lot
of kids and so they want to marry a
sister who's much younger but then by
the time that sister finishes her
education she's perhaps a little bit
past her prime and so now all of a
sudden mashallah she might be a
good-looking sister she might have good
education good family and everything
woloson from the brothers perspective
she is not as much of a high-demand
anymore and so unfortunately those
sisters now find it much much harder to
get married when if they had gotten
married a little bit earlier maybe
before finishing their education gotten
married to a good guy and then studied
together even or continued to study
after she got married it would have been
a much better outcome of the situation
so this is a reality I mean some of you
think someone like I might get offended
by that I hope not but we're trying to
choose not to but I want to but a
veteran us to tell them absolutely
because this is what's honest this is
really a reality what's what's going on
Zak yeah well I would love for people to
at least keep it in mind to know what
what the situation is instead of being
in denial
exactly and wouldn't it be better now
what was the substitute can she
continue school get married and have a
partner who helps facilitate this
absolutely yes I mean I have seen so
many young brothers and sisters who who
come to their parents and say you know
we want to save ourselves from Haram and
we would like to get married early just
as you said the profits of our salaam
encourage people to get married early so
that they protect themselves from other
evils of society and so when a brother
and sister who may both be students get
married there's absolutely nothing wrong
in them continuing to study in fact it's
beautiful they encourage each other and
inshallah many of them become very
successful in their careers and their
professions because they you know
motivated each other yes absolutely and
there's no such thing like people are so
so so scared of divorce now but then the
the door opens up and then they end up
they feel like they end up doing the
promiscuous thing they end up maybe
dating right I say okay you know now
they go towards the Haram and they end
up dating it's better isn't it better
now to divorce obviously this is
discouraged in Islam you want to really
keep the family unit and do everything
you can not to separate but at the end
it's not death to us part right that's
not that's not Islamic thing there's a
mercy there and if they do split is
better to actually divorce a hundred
time this is just one extreme example
than to do one time's dinner is that
right absolutely I mean divorce is
something that's frowned upon by certain
cultures and looked upon as if it's a
forbidden thing but it's not it's it's
actually completely allowed and
sometimes it's not only just allowed
it's actually recommended because if two
people are so incorrect for each other
and they're just harming each other
they're hurting each other's feelings
unannounced you know daily basis there's
no mercy there's no love in that
relationship
yes our Deen teaches us to give it your
best you know try every stone unturn and
and you know utilize every means you
have to reconcile but even the best of
the Companions of the Prophet SAW Islam
divorced and sometimes it's actually
necessary and and it it will insha'Allah
in most cases make the the brothers and
sisters life better because maybe they
would you know later connect with
somebody who's better for them inshallah
and
actually very honestly that is the case
with me I found a lot for reasons you
know I had to take a divorce after five
years of marriage and a hundred I'm very
happily married now and inshallah the
sister that you know my ex is happily
married and you know it's a beautiful
thing whereas if we forced ourselves to
stay married it may have been a much
worse outcome so alhamdulillah our Deen
is very merciful
it creates avenues for alternatives that
don't force you to be in an unhappy
miserable situation when we come back we
can take a break we're gonna talk about
you know the men shopping a lot right
okay this is another problem to keep
shopping shopping with like window
shopping yes and then you have
procrastination cold feet a lot of
brothers in there not man enough to step
up and take care of the responsibilities
it's true so we're talking about all
this and more here on the Deen show
don't go anywhere
this is my family's one night policeman
call me come on get him from the station
one fight here have a fight there his
physical beans was great burrows ego but
he left him empty I'm running here
running there and the outside people
looking in today this is a man everybody
knew Eddie at any given moment you have
70 women that are running around the
club looking way he did things that he
he pushed himself to the ethical
extremes that he could I have to get out
of this totally
right near the end there was this a boy
it was a constant struggle there was in
her soul that broken them there was that
emptiness in his eyes it was a big round
tennis that I think I've ever really
seen in his eyes it was dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde and he was struggling with that but
the habit was there there's a conscious
effort to make this quick
who hasn't started talking to her his
back look at him is fine the good guy
this was the reality lady's consequence
is when it starts on the slide the
spiritual anomalously well people didn't
know who I was
so what why are you doing this you're
living a dream people I have to be out
there
I'm trying to convince people to be on
the show the first episode of that show
aired I think that's when you saw the
formation come into the home these guys
changed what's going on here this is a
machine I know but to see someone change
the sees their character changes to see
was it of changes in their life it's a
sign of God back here on the D show
before we left we talked about there's
no depth until death do us part in Islam
where the mercies is that now that if
it's better to actually and this was
just going to the extreme divorce a
hundred or a thousand times and do it
come in peace leave in peace rather than
committing one act of zina fornication
adultery is that correct yeah we're on
it we concur with that and we talked
about window shopping what do we mean so
one of the problems I have seen with
especially younger brothers who are were
potentially looking to get married but
they're in their own minds they're
probably not as serious as they should
be and what I mean by that is sometimes
brothers will come across you know
sisters who are looking to get married
and they'll get
them a little bit and they like certain
things about the sister but not
everything is perfect which nobody is
perfect and so they you know kind of let
that sister go and then they meet
another sister and they keep doing this
over and over and over again to the
point where they have this very
unrealistic image of the kind of girl
they want to marry which consists of all
the good qualities that they've seen
across the you know 50 girls that they
met and now in their mind they have an
image that is just not practical and and
also at the same time they might
actually bump into a sister who is good
in most of the aspects but they feel
that little bit of fear what if I say
yes to this sister and then tomorrow a
better sister comes along when in
reality you know and what my teachers
have taught me is that the only way the
right person will come along is when you
make sincere thought well as for Natalya
and you say yeah I don't know what is
good for me only you know what's best
for me so you bring the right person to
me that will be beneficial for me in the
dunya & in the Hereafter
and and that's that's the right way of
doing it the other thing is you know
young brothers who maybe just finish
their education they have a good job
they have a nice car they have that
lifestyle of independent you know they
can stay up till 3:00 in the morning and
watch movies with their friends and of
course once you get married you you have
to be more responsible you have to give
time to your spouse you can't just
accept invitations whenever you feel
like it you know they're certain I
wouldn't call it difficulties but
certain adjustments you have to make as
a married person and brothers sometimes
who are ready to get married for all
practical purposes shy away from getting
married because they don't want to lose
that independence but in the process
they end up doing a lot of Haram which
like we mentioned you know is much much
worse than doing it the right way yes so
my advice humble advice to brothers
younger brothers who have a job who have
the right means to get married as our
Prophet SAW as mom said get married
early save yourself from Haram and you
know stop window shopping but make duaa
to Allah so Allah and Allah to send the
right person to you a woman is married
to property upon him said a person marry
for for things her lynnie
yes what else are the other four linear
linear linear wealth and quality yes
marry the one for her Dean you will be
successful right jealous so Dean is
number one a Halak character good
character and obviously there has to be
some kind of attraction between the two
right absolutely
so now you keep looking for a number you
know you went beyond 10 you want 11
right right I've been a woman you just
you've been a little bit too picky right
thanks exactly yes so now this is one
thing another thing is you got these a
real experienced brother just was
talking to a sister on one of these
matrimonial sites and they were talking
for some time and then finally it was
getting down to the nitty ingredient she
had all these demands on him right and
he was talking about you know you want
to pick out the engagement rings if I
want the wedding you know big Bollywood
Hollywood saw weddings you see this is a
problem - yes again you know some some
sister yeah well most sisters have this
this dream image of what their wedding
should be like it's the one event that
will only happen once in their lifetime
and you know from early age they plan it
out and you know the prophets of Islam
his advice was that the best marriage
and the marriage with the most amount of
blessings is the one that's very simple
simple and so them and and one of my
teachers says it beautiful he says you
know the husband and wife who are
looking to get married sometimes they
spend so much time and effort trying to
make the wedding perfect not realizing
that they themselves are not perfect and
not realizing that they're harming their
perfect marriage in trying to create the
perfect wedding
yeah and so you know this is this
happens a lot where the sister sometimes
also is doing it out of peer pressure
maybe her friends or her cousins had
this amazing wedding and now she wants
to outdo that wedding yeah and so in
trying to plan this special wedding
that's a lavish wedding she she's
causing undue pressure on the poor
brother who might be sincerely trying to
make it all happen but at the same time
she she might actually lose him you know
where he just gives up and he said I
can't I can't do this this is beyond my
means so and oftentimes what's worse
even is that they start the foundation
of their marriage on debt others spend
$50,000 there in the hole exactly where
they could have started
beautiful beginning by humble means so
you know again my sis my advice to
brothers and sisters is you know to do
what's reasonable but don't go above
your means where you cause more harm to
your marriage than good keep it as the
last final message and said keep it
simple we don't need to get into debt
right right before we even start and
then at the same time you see a lot of
weddings where you see one family trying
to outdo the other family and then it's
a shame you've got a lot of these
families you have you know the dancing
you have you know the rock bands hip hop
bands whatever the case alcohol and all
these other things far away from you
this is what advice do you have for this
again you know a lot of times people the
the brother and sister getting married
they want themselves to do this sort of
activity and shall Allah give us
guidance but sometimes brothers sisters
fall into family pressure yes the family
wants to do a family and the thing is
you know my advice again is to be firm
and steadfast and really with polite
beautiful words explain to your family
that I want Baraka and blessings in my
marriage for the next 50 years of my
life not just to please you for that one
night and destroy my marriage yeah and
so you know just with polite beautiful
words approach your family and say this
is something that's not allowed or not
encouraged in our religion and I want
for myself and for my husband or vice
versa to have blessings in my marriage
and so I would rather keep it simple
yeah yeah yeah start off right you and
right right
you got half naked wedding you know you
got doing it the wrong way is gonna end
up taking the wrong course and it's
gonna be something that you are going to
have to deal with and so for the
consequences and it's going to be a
wreck from the buttock ax exactly you
want America and hopefully we got so
many people excited about marriage now
should have seen some of the realities
that are going out there people can
relate with it so we bring it back to
the real world so give us an avenue now
that people can go you're gonna start
this new website talk about it yes so
the website that I'm just about to
launch actually just launched today it's
called Mirada matrimony calm and one of
the unique things about it is that it's
going to be the first website that's
supervised by a board of elimi by a
board of scholars who
will you know scrutinize it to make sure
everything is halal everything's legit
and clean there's no chances of
inappropriate activity and also the the
biggest source of advertisement for the
website will be Allah my own scholars so
that the kind of members we will get
will be high quality good practicing
Muslims who are looking for the same and
so inshallah that way we minimize the
frustration of people coming from a wide
variety of backgrounds who don't really
match with Cheeta he each other and you
end up wasting a lot of time because you
really are not looking for the same
thing and you know I in in contrast with
that I I would also you know bring some
of the experiences that I've had and
some of the expertise as a programmer
and somebody who's actually my expertise
is in security and privacy and so I will
inshallah
do my best to make sure that people have
a very safe and secure and wonderful
experience in looking for their
potential spouse while doing it in a way
that's pleasing to Allah subhanAllah
masha'Allah thank you very much may the
creator of the heavens reward you and
Devin same to you I mean thank you
take care Salone alaikum Salaam peace be
with you and we covered a lot of ground
in a short amount of time and hopefully
we stimulated you to run towards
marriage that we talked about women
making those high demands put a lot of
pressure on the brother brothers just
window-shopping having cold feet step up
you know it wasn't hard for you to go
try to get a girlfriend you're motivated
about that yeah I made all sorts of
phone calls you had a black book now you
threw it away
now be man enough to step up and go talk
to the Wally go talk to the woman that
you need to marry through the proper
channels the woman now Felicia look she
wanted to marry the prophets awesome she
stepped up also it's not just a one-way
street if you see a brother now that
maybe you want to marry go ahead to the
right channels make a connection there
but the thing is like we said we fight
to keep the family together when it is
finally an institution of marriage and
we don't want it to break but the point
we were making is better now that you
run towards marriage and you might mess
up along the way but you messed up in a
halal way you didn't do it in the wrong
way through sin out through fornication
to adultery so let's do things the way
they'll being but urke into our lives
simplicity we have these extravagant
style weddings that we talked about keep
it
well the problem peace be upon him said
that the best of marriages I have this
simple once and how do you know someone
loves you is right for you that person
brings you closer to Allah that person
brings you closer to your maker so
hopefully you've gotten to benefit from
being able to see on a Deen show and
continue to tune in every week follow us
on the Facebook to Twitter and
contribute towards the Deen show and
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you